well if you're looking for a way uh
speaking of kids to tire them out this
weekend maybe you're going to have some
fun bouncing around too check this out
it's big bounce america it's a craig
ranch regional park this weekend this
build is the biggest bounce house in the
world and who could argue giving us an
up-close look it's amanda huggins she's
the tour manager for big bounce america
and i can see her already uh jumping
around uh yeah show us how it works
because we're not sure how the bouncy
house works how do you bounce
i mean as long as you have to pe you are
good
we are basically operating this weekend
it's a three hour
session per um every three hours and
it's unlimited
to all of our inflatables and then our
world's largest bouncy castle that's the
only one that has a 45-minute time slot
other than that
as long as you have your shoes off and
your socks on party on wow you know it
seems it's so simple and they just
inflate something and jump on it for a
while you're part of this touring you've
been going all over the place
what what is the mat what is it like
that how much madness how what is it
like the atmosphere there when the kids
get really going
[Music]
i mean so first session it's kind of it
starts off slow 9 to 12. it's a little
early you know saturdays and sundays but
come come noon this place is filled with
lots of happy families so
it's all great fun rocking and rolling
amanda show us around just have armando
to uh pan around for us uh with the
camera and show us what it looks like
we are in our sports right now we have
some hoops back over there
we have our climbing rock tower over
there
and back over in this corner
is usually where we battle it out with
jousting sticks battle it out and this
is one of four you said bouncy houses
out there
correct so we have a slide we have our
sports we have two ball pits and we have
our main bouncy castle it looks like a
lot of fun
does everybody buy tickets and then
they're for a certain time and then
that's how you uh crowd control is that
right
correct so
a ticket as i said purchase them online
it's every our sessions are three hours
everybody receives a wristband upon
check-in and that's how we control who
is who well i think after three hours
we're pretty gassed after jumping around
in that thing for a while for all of
them
amanda thank you very much for showing
us around before she goes amanda i don't
really believe you can bounce there can
you show us a bounce can you just prove
that you really bounce in the house
really come on all right don't do it
there we go there it is
thanks amanda there's the bounce we were
missing all right do a somersault come
on let's see it
no no she's drawing the library